Now, fair game play has always been a requirement of multi-player games.
Although, it didn't always start that way. See back in the early 90s, video
game players were actual able to tweak some of their perimeters to get an
unfair advantage. Quake players, for example, would actually lower their
resolution on the graphics card to lowest quality setting, reducing the amount
of processing time required to process a frame, so they would actually get
higher frame rates. Another good example, that I'm not really, you know, bitter
about, or anything, was my Quake clan actually lost the last round of a very
expensive tournament because all of us were on dial-up while the other team was
all on DSL. Again, this was back before cable modems, again, not that I'm
bitter about that. The point is, that unfair game-play makes it bad for
everyone and then makes bitter people get bald. Since then, multi-player games
have actually done a lot to reduce this kind of cheating and unfair advantage,
but it is something that we had to worry about Inside of GRITS. See, if you're
actually using mouse controls, you have a lot more degrees of freedom because
there is more resolution to it than someone who is playing on a four pad
keyboard. We decided to actually attack this for GRITS because some of us were
bitter about losing unfair games in the past, and actually lock the mouse to
the same directional output that you get from a keyboard. Ensuring that both
players actually have a same and fair chance to play. Now, your designers
should mostly take care of this, but if you're one of those types that likes to
design and program make sure you start from the beginning worrying about fair
game play. Or you can create someone like this.